ce qu'il faut tout de même comprendre
que c'est que ce processus n'a de
référendum que le nom il a été annoncé
trois jours avant sa tenue des leaders
prorus dans ces régions où là se tient
ce dos scrutin ont déjà annoncé que le
résultat serait positif ce n'est pas un
référendum au sens où il n'y aura pas de
votre libre tout comme il n'y aura pas
de vrai dépouillement à le résultat est
connu ce sera oui à l'annexion comme
prévu par le Kremlin hier ici
excusez-moi et bien nous avons rencontré
une habitante qui récemment sorti de ses
territoires occupés par la Russie et
pour elle c'est référendum un peu
factice ne la surprennent pas du tout
pour elle elle nous a dit écoutez c'est
une suite logique elle a vécu cinq mois
sous occupations elle dit et bien les
autorités russes veulent effacer toute
trace de l'État ukrainien alors vous
l'avez dit évidemment Kiev a condamné
ses référendum tout comme et bien ses
alliés occidentaux et ça c'est important
parce que c'est là où on peut sentir une
petite inquiétude chez les
Ukrainiens parce que c'est avant tout le
soutien
occidental à l'Ukraine que le Kremlin
cherche à tester à travers ce processus
de scrutin factice parce que bien
évidemment une fois que ces régions
seront annexées et bien Moscou pourra
dire qu'une contre-attaque dans ses
régions c'est une contre-attaque contre
le territoire de la Russie elle-même
provoqué